All right, let's be honest. There are
people out there right now you don't
like. They come to mind immediately. And
the truth is there are also other people
that don't really like you. But how do
you communicate with these people when
you have to be with them at work or
around the house or in your community?
How do you talk to them? This episode is
all about how to talk to somebody who
doesn't like you. All that more coming
up. And I'm not exempt from this, by the
way, the whole people not liking you
thing. There are people that I can think
right now come to mind that I don't
like. And I know that there are people
listening, maybe probably not listening,
but maybe some that don't like me.
And that's okay, that's normal because
we're not meant to be for everybody,
right? There are people in your life
that if you were for everybody,
you kind of probably doing something
wrong. There's going to be somebody who
isn't a fan of what you're doing.
That's That's kind of a good sign in my
in my world. If somebody is not always a
fan of what you're doing cuz it means
that you're you're on the right track,
you're pushing, you're persevering. Not
everybody has to agree with what you're
doing. That's my That's my point. How do
you handle it? How do you handle it? How
do you talk to somebody who doesn't like
you or you don't like them? You ready?
Number one,
treat them like they like you.
Talk to them
like they like you. I know that sounds
counterintuitive. That's the point.
There are people that when you come into
the room and you know good and well they
don't like you, what they're looking for
is even more reasons not to like you.
But when you start treating them just as
normal as can be,
like nothing ever happened in the past,
it's going to not only bother them,
which is pretty cool. It's It's also
going to kind of go, "Huh, wait, this is
not This is not what I thought." And
sometimes they'll actually feel bad that
they even ever had the impression that
they didn't like you.
It could work either way. The point is
don't give someone a reason
to not like you because that that pulls
down your integrity.
You be you
is my point. You be you. Don't worry
about if they like you or don't like
you.
So, treat them in conversation just as
pleasant as I'm talking to you now. Big
disclaimer here. You ready? Big
disclaimer. This is not about being
fake. What I'm not telling you is to be
fake and pretend that everything's fine.
That's not it.
I can be cordial with you. I can be
kind. I can be polite. I can be
respectful without ever having to do
anything with whether I like this
person, prefer this person, I'm a fan of
this person or not. You just be you.
All right?
That's all that is.
So, if somebody's acting like they don't
like you, treat them even more so
like they like you.
Don't worry about what they're doing.
You concentrate on what you're doing,
right? And here's the key. Here's the
key takeaway and this is probably one of
my favorite points. Is if they don't
like you,
they're not that important. Most likely,
they're not that important.
If they genuinely don't like you,
they're not that important. Why? Because
they don't That means they don't know
you
well enough. They're not in a place
where they can really hold any kind of
judgment of you. That's That's really
going to weigh on you. So, what do you
do? Number one, treat them like they
like you.
What happens when you're around somebody
and you know you don't really like them
and they don't really like you
and you decide to kind of shift or shirk
them off or act a certain way. All it
does is double down
on their decision not to like you. All
it does is In their mind, they're going,
"Oh, I knew I didn't like this person."
Because they're They're all they're
doing is looking for ways to justify,
validate,
imprint that impression in their mind of
that they don't like you. So, when you
turn the tables and you act pleasant,
respectful.
You be you.
That messes with their head and they go,
"Huh, okay, maybe that wasn't the the
right the right impression that I was
supposed to have. Maybe that wasn't the
right impression I was supposed to
have." Number two, if you can't do that,
if you go, "No, Jefferson, look, I like
you, man, but no, I'm not I'm not doing
that." Here's what I want you to do. Go
neutral. Just go flat. That means I want
you to use neutral statements when
you're talking to them and you don't
want the conversation to go anywhere,
use words that
are stop to the conversation that you
can't do anything with. These are
neutral words like, "Got it." "Noted."
"Understood."
"Yep."
"Interesting."
Words that nobody can you can't continue
to take those words and go anywhere. So,
stay neutral in the conversation. If if
you really can't be at a place where you
can be pleasant around this person. If
you if you're really deciding that
you're just going to go sour, which I
get it. We're we're we're normal and
human. At least try to go neutral
where there's nothing negative you're
going to be doing. There's nothing
positive you're going to be doing. So,
use statements that keep the
conversation neutral. You're not
inflaming anything. You are going to use
statements that really can't do anything
with. So, if they talk to you,
instead of having this attitude or
making things worse or just confirming
their belief for whatever reason that
they don't like you or you don't like
them, it's got it. "Noted." "Thank you."
"Understood." "Appreciate it." You see
how I'm not even using full sentences?
It's not, "I appreciate that." It's
"Appreciate it."
Cool? Using very shortened versions that
are very neutral, very flat, nobody can
do anything with them. Number three,
keep
the sarcasm, the snarkiness at home.
All right? Instead, stick to facts.
If it's somebody who's does not like
you, instead of reinforcing, and
emboldening that emboldening that
decision of them, I think that's a word,
emboldening.
Let's say it is.
You get my point.
Instead of that, just stick to facts.
Here's what I mean. Let's say you're in
an office
uh at a meeting, and somebody comes in,
and you know you don't really like them,
they don't really like you, and they ask
a question, and they're like, "What did
I miss?" And you say, "Well, I mean, if
you were here, you would know."
That's sarcasm. That does nothing but to
make you feel better, and it's going to
make them dislike you even more.
Where you come in and and you go, "Well,
I mean, it would be nice if somebody
did."
Or well, if you were around, or if you
really cared, you'd find out. These
passive-aggressive comments, stop that.
So, just empty out the
passive-aggressive comments. They don't
do anything.
I know in that moment, cuz you kind of
want to jab them, right? You want to go,
"Mhm. Yeah, I know you don't like me, so
let me just poke you in the eye with
this stick."
Don't don't
don't do that.
All right?
Keep that at home. Instead, just stick
to facts.
Facts as reasons why you're here, and
why you're going to leave at some
certain future. So, let's say instead,
if they ask for the time, you're just
going to give the time. Don't give the
snarkiness. If you come in, say, "I'm
here to discuss this."
Or I need to talk to you about why.
There's not a Okay, well, I I got to
talk to you, and I I guess um Okay, I
guess we're doing this. Um so, I Here's
the thing.
Get rid of all that. Get rid of all of
it.
It's not serving you. It's not making
you a better person. Instead, just stick
neutral to the facts.
There's so much in this, because it's
natural for us to not like people.
Again, if they don't like you, they're
not that important and that's okay.
And I I can get down with the idea of
if you don't have somebody who's rooting
against you, it means you're not
going towards something important
enough. Like if you don't have
if if
if you're not chasing something, maybe
it's a business that you're building,
maybe it's a content that you're trying
to create, if you have people that are
the naysayers, the people that are uh
doubting you, then typically it means,
in my mind, your goals aren't big
enough.
Yeah, you need to reach for these goals
that are so big
and you feel like you're doing something
so important that of course you're going
to have people who are on the other side
of it. It's It's It's a healthy
It's a healthy thing. I know it's hard
to kind of
think in that mindset, but that's that's
at least my outlook. Means if if you
don't have people that are naysaying,
it's it's because your goals aren't
aren't big enough. Now, there are going
to be people out there that aren't going
to be fans of you just for whatever
reason. It doesn't matter. Typically,
they're jealous. Typically, they they
have some kind of preconceived notion.
They they gossip about you behind your
back. And we've addressed a lot of these
topics in the podcast and the podcast
episodes to come, but the point here is
don't give somebody a reason to not like
you just because you can. Don't allow
them to change who you are. Don't allow
them to lower your character or your
integrity because of some preconceived
notion. And and here's this other truth.
You ready? Opinions change.
There are people that I used to not like
and now I'm like, you know what? That
was kind of dumb of me back then. I I
actually like this person.
Or vice versa. And and it flips. You
think somebody's great and you realize I
I I got to know them and
uh
kind of empty inside. I don't I don't
agree. This doesn't match and align with
my values anymore. People change. My
guess, if you're listening right now,
there's somebody that you weren't really
a fan of and and then now you're like, I
kind of like this person.
It goes to the same thing with siblings.
You grow up as siblings. Like I know two
sisters who hated each other and now
they're like the best of friends.
It happens. Coworkers you're like, I'm
not really a fan of them. At the end,
you're you're great. Why? Because time
changes things. Always keep your head
above the water. Operator frequency that
says, I'm going to be true to me
regardless of what anybody else is going
to do. So, what do you do? How do you
talk to somebody who doesn't like you?
Number one, act like they do.
Treat them like they like you. Talk
exactly like they like you. Why? Because
that is your choice. And you're not
allowing their your pre- preconceived
notion of what they think about you to
control any of your behavior. Are you
with me?
Good. Two, if you can't do that, keep
your emotions in a vacuum. That means
you're going to use neutral flat
statements that don't do anything.
Like, thanks. Got it. Understood.
It's not the best, but at least it's
going to keep you flat. Number three,
keep all of the passive-aggressive
sarcastic comments at home. Things that
are going to
flare it up, leave that alone. Instead,
just operate on the facts. Why you're
there, what you need to talk about, get
in, get out, get safe. And keep in mind,
opinions always change.
>> Before we keep going, I want to take a
moment to tell you about Timeline. When
we talk about aging well or healthy
aging, we usually first start talking
about diet or sleep or exercise. And
those are all great, but we can also
continue to look down at the cellular
level. If you remember mitochondria,
remember the powerhouse of the cell?
Well, it's true, they store cell energy.
And as we get older, those cells don't
deliver that energy nearly as
efficiently. They get damaged, they get
old, they get tired. Well, that's why I
take Mitopure from Timeline. It supports
something called mitophagy, which is
your body's natural process for clearing
out damaged mitochondria so your cells
can produce energy more efficiently.
Timeline has spent over 15 years
researching mitochondrial health and
human clinical studies and people saw
improvements in muscular strength and
energy without changing their routine.
So for me, this is about staying strong,
staying sharp, and feeling like myself
as I continue to age. And they come in
these flavors that are delicious. I only
took two and then realized on the bottle
I could take four, so I started taking
four cuz they're just that delicious.
Timeline's clinically proven formula is
now available at new lower price. You
can go to Mitopure now. Starts at $79
when you go to timeline.com/jefferson.
Go to timeline.com/jefferson
to learn more. And now, let's keep
going.
>> How do you communicate your worth
when someone is being offensive or
adding a little digs underneath their
language?
Maybe they're trying to get a message
across,
um,
and they're frustrated, so they're
saying a few things that would be
offensive to you potentially or maybe
hurt you or maybe kind of put you
beneath.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you
create a boundary
cautiously
with them so that they don't keep doing
that in the future where it's
letting them know, "Hey, this this type
of communication doesn't really work for
me. It's not okay." And And owning your
worth.
>> Yeah.
>> While also being able to throw it away
at the same time and not let it get to
you. Like how do you navigate that so
that they don't that doesn't continue to
happen in friendships or in
relationships or in career
>> Right.
>> where that doesn't continue. Like I
understand we can do it once and twice
and three times, but if someone's always
doing that to us,
>> Right.
>> how do we create create that boundary
and and cautiously communicate our
worth?
>> Depending on the context of who that
person is, you know, who who they are in
your life. Some people you just can't
get away from. I mean, our family
members, what have you, but it's a
balance of your value and then what
we're going to just call as what I'm
interested in. So, somebody we're going
to say something that's offensive in a
way and they they are pushing me.
It's a much more powerful move, a very
dominant, assertive move to say, "I'm
not interested
in returning what you just gave." Oh,
wow, that's a
>> It's a power move.
>> Yeah, oh yeah, and see it's a
>> So, if I say, "Jefferson, you know,
it was pretty idiotic what you did the
other day to me and I I just didn't, you
know,
>> Yeah.
>> you just looked like an idiot, but I
what I really want to do is is I want
moving forward I want us to go and do
this thing instead."
>> Right. Yeah, yeah, I'm with you. Yeah,
yeah, I'm with you. Yeah, I'm with you.
>> How would you respond to something like
like that?
>> So, if somebody Well, what you kind of
did was
you you like hid it into something else
that they did.
So, what I I would first do is call that
out. So,
I what I hear two points.
Yeah, and so I'm like I'm not going to
skip that. So, I'm going to say
>> Okay, so you want to you want to just
throw the trash away right away. You got
it. You address it.
>> Well, because they're trying to hide the
trash in the good and so I my response
is well, I see two different things. So,
the first point I don't have an interest
in responding to whatever or I'm going
to say, "Well, maybe I did look like an
idiot, but
I'm not going to be I'm not going to be
holding on to whatever message you're
trying to send to me." But it's a it's
much more dominant move to say, "I have
no interest
in returning what you sent."
>> Right. I have no interest in calling you
what I saw yesterday you do or something
like that.
>> You got it. But if you use the phrase I
have no interest I have no interest in
in talking about your opinion of my
performance.
>> Oh, interesting. know what I mean? Like
it's obviously that's not something you
want to start off with cuz that could
sound that could sound defensive. That
could sound issues, but the point of it
is
when you say I have no interest you're
letting them know like I don't have an
it's like you're saying that as you're
doing the trash can thing. I really
don't have any interest in
you know, this this kind of food. It's
not great for me. It doesn't really
settle well with me. But what does taste
good of what you said, you know, about
X, Y, and Z. And so you kind of imagine
those words as part of it.
Let's say it's you know, your diet.
Sorry, I'm a little lactose intolerant,
but
>> Right.
>> So let's let's skip the milk and
talk about something else.
>> If you want to talk to someone you
completely disagree with, here's what I
want you to do. We're going to get right
to it. Number one,
don't argue the opinion.
Identify the need.
Identify the need. Number two, shift
from proving to understanding.
And number three, water your own garden.
Don't waste your water trying to water
their bad seeds. All right? Water yours
and they'll get curious why yours is
doing so well. Water your own garden.
We're going to go into depth on those.
Number one,
don't argue the opinion.
Identify the need. Let's go deeper on
that. What does that mean? So many times
in conversation, you are let's say
you're at the dinner table and you have
family members, in-laws, whatever it is.
And somebody brings something up
and there's all of a sudden that tension
in the room. They go, "Oh god.
Oh my gosh. He They just they went
there. They they they talked about it.
They talked about that candidate. They
talked about that platform, that
opinion, that that whatever it is. Maybe
you think it's a old mindset. It's an
out-of-date mindset. It's a um it's it's
not a nice it's not good to bring up.
It's it's not cooth. Whatever it is,
it's going to bring you tension, right?
And the what you want to do is start
arguing the opinion. You're arguing the
very top,
the tip of the iceberg. We get caught in
trying to argue somebody's opinion. If
they were to say, "Well, I believe that
so-and-so is the best for this." Or they
obviously
"This issue in our country is the worst
it's ever been." And you want to argue,
"No, it's not. Actually, we need this."
And you have this different opinion.
You're just talking about the tip of the
iceberg. But what breaks that down is
that you're never going to get them to
come your way, and you're never going to
get to theirs.
You don't have to share their
opinion
to have a valuable conversation.
What you have to do first is identify
the need.
The tip of the iceberg, what's the
bottom of it is the need. And it usually
has to do with safety
or control
or fear.
Typically, fear of change.
And if you don't If you choose not to
hear their words as God, I cannot
believe they want to vote for that
person. Instead, you hear it as
they're afraid of change. They have a
fear of this. They have a fear of that.
It was told to me once that
nobody says anything for the purpose of
being wrong.
Nobody has an opinion and gives an
opinion for the purpose of being wrong.
Even the people who begin with, you
know, I could be wrong about this, they
never think they're wrong about it, do
they?
No, they always think that they're
right. And if you go from that mindset,
instead of looking at the tip of the
iceberg, instead of the tops of the
trees, you're looking at the roots
of what is the need. It's their need for
safety
for people around them, for their own
safety. Usually, it is all based in fear
and that, or what their value is and how
for kids or for their life or how people
should do and and and live and things
that really
should have no effect on them whatsoever
but yet they've decided they're going to
have a big opinion on it right now.
What you're hearing is the year of
change. Things should be better. They
were always better back in the day.
If it was just how it was back when I
was a kid,
it's always the fear of change. This is
never a topic that's going to expire.
So, how do you talk to somebody you're
never going to agree with? At any any
level, don't argue the opinion. That's
going to go nowhere. Instead, identify
the need. What does that sound like,
Jefferson? What does that sound like?
It sounds like you saying, "Hey, I I
agree this is worth talking about. You
know what? I I can hear that you really
care about the safety of this. I can
hear you you
uh
you don't want things to to change." Or
maybe it's as simple as
"I hear that safety is a big thing for
you.
I hear that
this political ideal is important to
you.
I hear how
the future of
this country is important to you. How
you begin to
simply acknowledge
the need
rather than arguing the opinion.
Another one, it sounds like you really
care about this. It sounds like you
really care about this. You know what
they're going to say? Yeah. Yeah, I
really do. And all of a sudden you're
going to start to break down that it's
it's a deeply rooted need that they have
typically for
control. That's That's what you're
hearing.
Don't argue the opinion.
Don't even address that. Instead,
identify the need. Ways that I even like
to
I explain that is I might say, "I agree,
but I go macro, not micro." So, I might
say, "I agree this is worth talking
about. I I agree that's one way to look
at it.
I agree that's an opinion."
Or I might say that's helpful to know.
That's well, you know what? That's
helpful to know.
Or I might thank them. Hey, well, thank
you for sharing that. You see, I'm not
having to agree with anything that they
said. I'm just acknowledging the need
that they have, that is deeply rooted
need. If you only respond to the
opinion,
they will argue you forever. If you only
disagree
or argue the opinion, they will push it
forever. I can promise you that is a
conversation at the dinner table that
will last months if not years
if you continue to push on that. But, if
you identify and discuss and talk about
the need, the issue underneath, you can
actually make
progress. You can actually make
progress. That's where you want to go.
Number two, be more interested in
understanding rather than proving.
Proving is this mindset of no, you have
to agree with me. No, I have to make you
understand my way. You know what? I I
can't even
I can't even wrap my mind around how you
could possibly think this. Are you
kidding me? You actually think
Is that ever going to make anybody agree
with you? Whenever you come on the
offensive to prove something or you go,
are you kidding me? Do you really
believe this?
It The more you tell somebody they're
wrong, the more convinced they are that
they're right. Or they all of a sudden
clam up and go, well, I'm not going to
share my opinion with you. This is what
I believe. So, I don't care. Evidence
doesn't work. Facts don't work. Why?
Because you're only hitting the opinion.
You're not identifying the need like we
talked about in number one. So,
what do you do instead of trying to
push, push, push and prove, prove,
prove? Because you know what that feels
like. What does that do? That makes you
harden even more. Instead, ask questions
that help open up understanding. These
are not questions that begin with why.
That will kill it instantly. Well, why
do you think that? Why do you believe
that?
Uh yeah, okay.
What about anything that challenges the
why to make them explain in a defensive
posture. But if I begin with what, how,
when, where,
those are what they call open-ended
questions. Open-ended questions. So if I
were to say,
how long have you felt this this way?
Oh, well, you know what? I've I felt
this the first time in Oh, what what
happened there?
Where
where did you hear this?
You hear how I'm not going Yeah, right.
Well, okay, explain to me how X, Y, and
Z. That's going to clam up.
Right? But if I were to say, where did
you Where did you learn this?
How long have you felt that way?
And I'm actually interested in
understanding, they will explain to you
more. And what's going to happen in that
thread, you're going to go, "Ha, okay,
there's the the need
of something that happened to them
probably that they just believe in.
Sometimes,
especially I would say in the political
area, you you see all this stuff where
they like they interview people on the
street, right? And they try and catch
them on something and they might mention
something of a different political
candidate. And all of a sudden the the
person who's being interviewed is
talking like they know and it's actually
inaccurate information.
It's because
people have opinions that are based on
feelings, based on the inner needs, not
typically based on facts. So that's why
evidence doesn't work.
Proving to them, saying, "Look at this
piece of paper. How could you possibly
Look at this report that came out." That
doesn't work because it doesn't address
the inner need within. So when you ask
the open-ended questions to get them to
open up to you
and help you understand, it helps
identify the need and it makes them feel
acknowledged, it de-escalates the
situation, and it helps have a
productive conversation that actually
moves, rather than just creating a big
mess where somebody has to get up from
the table and walk away because, you
know what, I'm over this. You're never
going to change.
Number three, water your own garden.
Water your own garden. I I I love this
illustration in my mind because
so much peace can be had. If If you're
somebody who gardens, you know what kind
of peace that brings. I've We've had
gardens.
Um and
it is you tend to it. You pay attention
to it. You protect it, and you water it.
And so much of conversation is
understanding
I can only tell it to you. I can't
understand it for you. So, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to water my own
garden, meaning I'm going to make sure
my people are protected.
By protecting my peace, I also protect
my people, the people who care about me,
the people that need me in the right
state of mind, who who need me to be
present.
If I am so worked up about opinion of
yours that that will have no impact on
my life whatsoever at this meal or at
this gathering, right? I'm I'm I've lost
sight of the fact that I have a
beautiful garden.
If I start arguing against your opinion,
what I do is I get my water hose, and
I'm all of a sudden I'm trying to water
yours when they've planted bad seed.
And what's that going to grow?
It's going to grow thorns. It's going to
grow animosity. It's going to grow
contempt.
And all of a sudden what could have been
a 5-minute conversation of acknowledging
the differences, there is now 5 years of
estrangement. That's what happens.
That's how quick it happens.
When you understand that if they can
have their own opinion and have their
garden,
let them have it, and you have yours.
So, you can hear conversations from them
and say, "You know what,
I'm not trying to change your mind." Or,
"You know what? I I know I'm not going
to change your mind. I just want to hear
what you have to say." Or, "I appreciate
what you're sharing. I know we're not
going to see that eye to eye on this.
But, you know what we do make eye to eye
on?
Whatever topic
that you know that you agree on."
Choosing
when to go into that conversation,
knowing when to get out of it.
Usually, we just get very stubborn. We
get really stubborn.
And we try to go to number two, and we
just prove, prove, prove, prove. And
that does nothing. So, remember when it
comes to watering your own garden,
that there will be an end to the
conversation. And there certainly can be
a place for meaningful dialogue. What I
playfully like to say is, if somebody is
trying to have some kind of conversation
with me,
whether it's
is if it's something I know I disagree
with,
I might easily say, "You know what? I'd
rather hear about you."
They ask me a question that's kind of
sent to tee me up.
It's me saying, "Well, I'd rather hear
about you." Nobody gets mad
if I suggest talking about themselves.
I've never had that once. They go, "Oh."
They kind of laugh as if like, "All
right, I understand we're not going to
go there."
And sometimes, you know, even like
my grandparent,
my grandfather, you know, he will try
and spark these arguments just for fun.
They can get me really worked up, and it
doesn't doesn't bother him at all. Maybe
you can relate to that.
And it's me having to choose to just
water my own garden. I love him. I'll
always love him. That doesn't mean I
have to agree with everything that he
says. Okay, what do we got? Number one,
don't argue the opinion.
Identify the need. Go deeper. Number
two,
instead of talking to prove,
talk and respond to understand.
Again, we're going layer to layer layer.
And number three, water your own garden.
Protect your own peace.
Don't be walking over and start trying
to pick their weeds.
All right?
Water your own garden.
That's the key to a lot of peace in your
life. Have you ever been talking out
loud and while you're talking somebody
says, "Well, you know what I think is"
and they just run right over you. What's
the first thing you think? You go, "Oh,
okay. I guess I'll stop talking." Now
all of a sudden they are controlling the
floor. Now they're dominating the
conversation and you really don't have
another window and you feel defeated.
What do you do when somebody is talking
over you? Well, there's a wrong way to
go about it and a right way to go about
it and I'm going to teach you both.
Now if you listen to the rest of this
podcast, you were going to learn exactly
how to stop it when somebody tries to
dominate the conversation. You ready?
The wrong way to go about this is when
you start to yell and start to try and
get more attention to you. Somebody
starts interrupting you and the first
thing you say is, "Oh, excuse me. Am I
interrupting you?" Or oh, is the end of
my sentence interrupt the beginning of
yours? That kind of trying to be cute
language that never works. Let me tell
you why it doesn't work because it makes
you look desperate. So whenever somebody
is dominating the conversation and
interrupts you,
the worst thing you can try and do is
trying to take it back from them. When
you try to out attention them, that
never works. It always puts you in a
weaker position. Why? Because it looks
like you're grasping for control. That
is the wrong way to go about it.
Instead, this is what I want you to do
when somebody tries to dominate the
conversation and talk over you. You
ready? Number one, I want you to
continue talking exactly as you were.
Keep the same volume. Keep the same
tempo. Keep the same pace.
Keep talking just like you were. Do not
stop. So when everybody whenever that
person at the board meeting and your
wherever you are, they start to try and
catch in, and start and talk over you.
Well, I think Well, what about and they
and they try and talk over you.
Keep talking exactly where you are.
This works because it shows a
discrepancy between your very even keel,
controlled, I'm going to continue
talking no matter what you say, even if
you interrupt me, I am planted, I'm
grounded, I do not care what you say.
Whenever you keep that same plane, and
they are just yeah, yeah, yeah, barking
way up here, trying to get your
attention, trying to get everybody
else's attention, it shows that
discrepancy of you being very
controlled, and them trying to grasp for
control. They're trying to get that
attention from everybody else,
while you are the one staying calm and
controlled. So,
number one is continue to talk. Don't
stop talking. All right, number two,
what I want you to do is resist the
temptation to raise your voice.
We always want to try and outtalk the
other person.
Whenever somebody starts raising their
voice, it's very natural, it's very easy
for us because we're trying to
kind of
uh jump over them. We're trying to It's
like playing checkers, you want to kind
of jump over them, you want to get on
top of the conversation, you want to
dominate it in some way.
Anytime you do that,
all it does is escalate them to talk
even more. That's how shouting matches
happen. Like if you watch the news, and
you see the talking heads on the news,
and the people that are just fighting,
just arguing to argue,
or if you watch like sports commentary,
maybe on ESPN or something, and and you
hear people taking two different
positions, and somebody's interrupting
the other, and somebody's interrupting
the other, and they just start kind of
yelling back and forth. Who's listening?
Nobody. What do you do? You change the
channel. Nobody's learning anything.
Nobody can get anything from that
because it's just a power grab for
attention. So, you're going to resist
that. All right, you're going to resist
that by continuing to keep your volume
exactly as it is. Why? Again, it shows
that discrepancy. That's what you want.
Number three, we're just swinging right
at it today. We're going we're going
straight for the throat. Anytime that
that person is trying to
dominate the conversation or interrupt
or continue talking and you don't feel
like you have a window, let's say we're
at a a board meeting and they're just
continuing to talk and you don't feel
like you have a window into it. Here's
the key. Use their name. People love to
hear their name. There's no sweeter
sound than the sound of their own name.
So, if they're talking and they're
droning on and they've kind of taken
away the conversation and gone on with
their own voice and with their own
subject and they think what they're
saying is the most important thing, I
want you to use their name.
Use their name. So, let's say
I it's me. Let's me I I'm the big bad
guy right now and I am I've just taken
over the conversation. You're talking to
me
and I go, "Well, well, you know what I
think is you you ought to go You know
what you should do?" And I just start
going on away in my own views, opinions
and I'm talking to an audience of one.
If you need to get my attention, what I
want you to say is, "Jefferson."
That'll pop my head quick. Jefferson.
You're not raising your voice. You're
not saying it angry.
You're not saying it too um tender,
almost too hesitant. You're going to say
it strong. You're going to say it clear.
Jefferson.
If I keep talking, say it again.
Even if you need to raise the volume a
little bit. It's going to get my
attention. It's going to get the other
person's attention. They are going to
stop because they hear their name.
That's where That's the window. You've
now created the window into that
conversation.
Where I want you to use the phrase talk
over.
Say something like, "It's not helpful
when you talk over me."
Or, "I feel like you're talking over
me."
Or, "I can't hear you when you talk over
me." I say the very similar thing when
somebody's interrupting you, which in
this case is very related. I can't hear
you when you talk over me.
Anytime you're using that phrase talk
over, it's clueing them in to exactly
what they're doing. Sometimes people
don't understand what they're doing.
They don't realize what they're doing.
It maybe it's not on purpose,
but that's beside the point. The The
The fact is they're doing it. So, you
have to take action. You can't just be
quiet and let them continue to talk and
and you and you feel less and then you
feel more dismissed. That kind of
behavior
is something that you need to catch
immediately.
You can't let it keep going on. Why?
Because
you're otherwise
establishing a pattern of how they can
treat you, how they can talk to you.
That it's just a given that your opinion
does not matter as much as theirs. But,
if you catch it, Jefferson,
I can't hear you when you talk over me.
It's not helpful for you to talk over
me.
Jefferson, are you interested in my
thoughts or do you want to talk over me?
It depends how direct you need to be. I
You're the one who knows the personality
of the person that you're dealing with.
But, that is exactly how I want you to
handle when somebody is talking over
you. I had something very similar
when I was a young associate at a law
firm.
There was a another associate of mine
and she had great ideas, but she never
felt like she could really share them
in the meetings that we'd have. And we'd
have other associate meetings. There'd
be about eight to 10 of us.
And she didn't feel like she could
really use her voice that way. She was
much more hesitant,
but still she had wonderful ideas and
there were times where I would kind of
focus the conversation to tee it up so
she could talk, but at the same time I
didn't always want to be the crutch that
goes, "Oh, she Let me help guide the
conversation to her." So, I talked to
her about it. Said, "This is what I want
you to do. The next time David
starts to bounce over onto your
conversation, I want you to use his name
and watch what happens.
Sure enough, while she's giving an idea
of what she thinks we should try and do
for the upcoming year, David immediately
kind of goes on the attack.
It You ever had somebody who
in a meeting, specifically in a group,
that
just wants to always feel like they can
go right for you? They can go right for
you every time. That
For some reason, you're you're their
scapegoat. For some reason, you're the
outlet for them that they As soon as you
start talking, boom, there they there
they go. Something about it triggers
you. Triggers them.
It was the same way with in this
relationship.
And so, she started talking, boom, David
goes in.
And first thing she had said she did was
continue to talk exactly how she was.
What did it do? It didn't make her look
weak, it made him look weak because it
looked like he was trying to get in in
the conversation and she was totally
ignoring it. Who we listen to? We
started listening to her, not him.
Because it showed everybody in the room
what he was doing was not acceptable as
a group, as a community. He was now
making himself kind of as the outsider.
What she did next as he continues to
talk is she used his name.
She used his name and he snapped to
attention.
David,
you're talking over me.
That's all she said.
You know what he did? Immediately
apologized. Why? Because he's looking
around and seeing everybody kind of
agrees.
Nobody was fighting, nobody was sticking
up for him. He's like, oh, I'm I'm you
know what? I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Go go
ahead. Never again did he do that.
So, I want you to really think about
this. The next time that somebody is
trying to dominate a conversation, some
somebody's trying to speak over you.
Number one, what I want you to do
is to continue to talk. Two, resist the
temptation to raise your voice to out
talk them because that's a weaker
position, ultimately. Three, what I want
to make sure that you do is realize the
power of somebody's name.
So, if they keep on talking, use their
name. It is going to snap their
attention. It's going to make them stop
because they need to hear what comes
after their name, why you're using the
sweet sound of their name. That's your
window to be able to communicate exactly
what's happening into action. All right?
Sound good?
I love this kind of stuff. It's awesome.
Quick, to the point, you can do it. I
know that you can.
>> You don't have to attend every argument
you're invited to.
>> Yeah.
>> That's brilliant.
>> Thank you. It is a a mindset of instead
of the default where somebody is
engaging in opinion with you. Like we're
opinion-making machines.
>> Mhm.
>> Something happens in the world, where
where does everybody turn to? Social
media to share their opinion to who
their audience of six people that, you
know, are on their Facebook or
something. And they
And they go and they flood all the
comments of how much they agree, they
disagree, and who's attacking who, and
who's a snowflake, and who's the
whatever.
And that kind of behavior solves is
nothing. In fact, it's very draining. In
fact, if we want to say that's a symptom
of a very bad health. Uh you know, a lot
of the times those kind of people are
are unhealthy, not just physically, but
mentally un- unwell. All right? So, if
you want to make sure that you stop
attending every argument you're invited
to, you need to understand that there's
a priority of what's important in your
life.
There are people that disagree with you,
and there are people who maybe don't
even like you.
Most likely, if they don't like you,
they're not that important.
You know, I Who Who do you want to keep
in your life? Yeah, who who do you want
to surround yourself with? And I feel
like anytime somebody gives you an
invitation to an argument, we go, "Oh,
yep, absolutely. Check yes, I will be
attending."
And that's a that's a one-way ticket to
um bad health.
>> It comes down to emotional awareness,
self-awareness, emotional regulation,
doesn't it? Because
when you are more self-aware and
emotionally regulated,
I think it becomes easier to
not attend every argument. When your
nervous system is in
high alert, when you've been busy with
work all day, you didn't take a lunch
break, you're in sort of that stress
mode,
>> Yeah.
>> it's sometimes harder to separate.
>> Right.
>> And I think sometimes fear is also what
gets in the way of many things in our
life, but also
our ability to communicate well, right?
And I think the more we're better to
emotionally regulate, the more better
able we are to go, "Hey, you know what?
I don't I don't want to get involved
with that."
>> Yeah.
>> You know, something I've learned being
online sharing information for
that, about 12 years now, is
I don't have to have an opinion on
everything.
>> Yeah, or or you can have an opinion and
not share it.
>> Yeah, I certainly don't need to have a
public opinion on everything. Now,
people can expect me to.
>> Right.
>> I should be commenting on this event.
Great.
No problem.
I don't think I should.
>> Right.
>> I don't want to, and ultimately it's up
to me what I what I will and what I
won't communicate on, right? It's kind
of interesting. What have you learned,
right? This is interesting. You were
already an exceptional communicator.
You started sharing things online in
2022, so about 3 years or so.
You've had a lot of experience with
comments on social media. So, what
what has being on social media and
reading comment sections
taught you
about other human beings?
>> You know, I I'll tell you
I'm blessed with a wonderful audience. I
I can probably count on a one hand,
truly, the amount of times I've had a a
negative troll type of just nasty
>> Wonderful.
>> comment, which is just
>> Wonderful. And most of the time they're
>> they're bots, you know, they're not
they're not real.
Um
but what I have seen of course because
I'm on social media like you are,
I've seen
people leave negative horrible comments
in YouTube, TikTok, Instagram, you name
it, where
the quick little clapback that's ugly,
maybe on somebody's
weight, appearance, looks, what they
said,
and it gets a lot of likes,
like a crazy
>> Yeah.
>> amount of likes because
there's this anonymity
of being behind the keyboard, and you
almost in some sense get rewarded for
it. When somebody is liking your
comment, what are you encouraged to do?
Say more ugly things
to get more like and appreciation, and
uh the the that dopamine hit of your
you're doing something well. So, what I
have seen
is that people in comments can be
I've seen it both ways. I've seen the
negative side of it, and it's
detrimental.
I've also seen the very positive side of
people can create a community in the
comments, and you take something like
TikTok for example. Sometimes the
comments are more entertaining than the
actual content itself. People
immediately what they would say run to
the comments
because there's so much interaction or
things that are funny. People are
hilarious.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, I one thing about social media
is it there's so many talented people
and so many funny people that you would
never know. You know, they're total
totally
total introverts,
but they're funny and creative and
things you would never be able to see in
the the world and environment that
you're that you're in. So, I've been
blessed with being able to see the
positive. I've been blessed with being
able to see the
the negative of it in in social media.
And I find
I mean, I'm certainly a product of it. I
wouldn't be here with you today had
people not resonated with the
the content that I make.
>> I would bet that one of the reasons you
don't get many negative comments is
because of your energy.
>> Mhm.
>> People respond to energy.
They they do. You know, we all respond
to energy and the vibe of the people
around us. And so, if you're putting out
content with a really
warm
compassionate, grounded energy with a
real desire to help people,
>> Right.
>> it's just not going to lead to that many
people, you know, trying to meet that
energy with division and criticism. Do
you know what I mean? Whereas some
people, their whole brand is about
calling out or this is what's toxic or
whatever it might be.
>> whatever it is.
>> That energy is going to attract more
energy like that,
>> Right.
>> which is super interesting. I mean, I
also very rarely get negative comments,
um but I've always had a rule actually,
an internal rule with myself, which is
which maybe I didn't follow in the early
days of being, you know, online sharing
information, but I've learned through
the process, which is it comes back to
some of your teachings in this book,
right? Which is
if I'm not feeling calm,
do not respond to a comment.
>> So true.
>> You know, don't do it.
>> Yeah.
>> It's never going to come go well, you
know? Only respond. So, sometimes it's
like I I think, "Actually, that's worthy
of a response. Like, I I feel that'd be
a good to interact with that, but only
do it when you're feeling calm." And
calm doesn't just mean my internal
state, it also means what's going on in
my life.
>> Yes.
>> Right? It's more important that I'm
going to spend quality time with my
children or my wife or going around to
to my mom.
>> Yes.
>> Actually, you know what? That is more
important than a random comment on my
Instagram page.
>> Absolutely. And probably the truth is
that's one comment out of 200. You know
what I mean? And so you have you might
have 199 wonderful comments and we see
that one and we kind of go
and we want to comment right there. And
you know, it does nothing. I get
questions. I know you get questions of
people. When I post, I get negative
comments and or you know, how do you
handle it? And I go, do you have to?
What do you what I mean, the algorithm
doesn't care if it's happy or sad. It's
a comment. At the same time, do you know
this person? Are you going to actually
sit down and spend time with this
person? What's going on in your life?
Yeah.
>> I sort of in in my in my last book Jeff
said May Change Your Life has a chapter
called Take Less Offense.
Okay, I think you'd really enjoy it
actually. And
um
in that chapter I make the case that
offense is something we choose to do,
right? Nothing is inherently offensive
because if it was,
we'd all find the same thing offensive.
>> Yeah, I love that.
>> The fact that we don't means it's not
the comment or the thing that was
causing the offense. It was something
within us that was being activated.
>> Right.
>> Right, I'm not excusing poor behavior
here. I'm just saying that nothing is
inherently offensive. We're choosing to
take offense. Right? And I'm I sort of
also make the case in that chapter
that on some level
taking offense is actually or could be
argued to be a little bit arrogant.
And and and the reason I say that is
because if you think about it
rationally, there's 8 billion people on
the planet.
Right?
Is it reasonable to believe that every
other human being on this planet is
going to have the same view and
perspective on the world as I do? No.
Right? It's not reasonable at all.
Clearly some people in the world are
going to see the world differently from
me. They're going to have different
ethics, different religion, uh different
way of being brought up, uh different
levels of trauma, whatever it might be.
They're going to see the world
differently. So, they may actually
disagree with me on certain things. They
may see things completely differently.
It doesn't mean that they're wrong and
I'm right or I'm right and they're
wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> Just means they see it differently.
>> Yes.
>> And I And I kind of feel, bringing it
back to
your book, one of the things I love
about it is I think there's a real deep
compassion
behind the tools.
>> Mhm.
>> Which relates to what I just said, which
is you don't know what's going on with
that person, you know? What the person
you see is not always the person you're
talking to.
>> Yes.
>> And that's I think one of the things I
love the most about it.
>> Yeah, well, thank you very much. I think
you're absolutely right. You choose to
take offense to certain things. And I
I'm of the mindset of anytime
you just hear change,
you hear about change, it makes you
uncomfortable.
You hear about change in the world or
somebody having a different political
view than you. That's change you're
hearing and makes you go, "I don't like
that."
So, whenever you find and hear that
change is being communicated to you and
makes you uncomfortable, that creates a
lot of that fear because we like what is
safe. We like what is known. You Let's
say I want to change your mind about
something and you have this political
view. Let's say it's a religious view,
for example. I And And I say that as
something that's typically very
crystallizing as part of somebody's
identity. Well, if I just expect in one
conversation I'm going to entirely
disprove everything that you've ever
believed, problems are going to happen.
Because what's most likely is I'm not
just saying you're wrong.
I'm saying your parents are wrong. I'm
saying your grandmother's wrong. I'm
saying that thing that you learned when
you were a kid and you've known your
entire life is all wrong. And people
will
will do anything
far past the point of just deciding not
to listen to you in order to preserve
what they know.
And it is so easy for people That's why
a lot of times in a political climate,
they're okay with one candidate doing
it. They're not okay with another
candidate doing it. They're okay if it's
the side I am comfortable with. I'm not
good with if it's the side I don't agree
with. Why? Because
we feel comfortable with what we know
because it's comes down from the people
that put their value in us and we will
defend the people in our lives that have
contributed to that view. So, in other
words, you can say I'm wrong, but if
you're saying my dad's wrong Well, well,
well, well, well, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Don't You don't get to say
my dad's wrong. I'm the one. And so, we
get defensive on behalf of the people
that help shape our identity. And so, we
will do anything
to the point of just refusing to listen,
even to logic, even to evidence, even
somebody presents you with evidence of
saying something of why your position is
wrong on it, we will bold-face just
disagree with it in order to protect
the values that we've been raised with.
>> Yeah. It's a great point. I mean,
obviously you are an American citizen
and
you know, American politics is
uh very interesting these days.
>> Yeah, let's keep it to that word. Yeah,
yeah.
>> very interesting and
I think 12 months ago the statistic that
I came across uh was that one in six
US adults are not talking to another
family member because of a difference of
opinion Yeah. over politics, which I
found utterly remarkable. Right? And
really just speaks to what you just
said, right? And I guess
that in many ways highlights why a book
like yours is so important, right?
Because it should be possible
for two people with completely different
religions or completely different
political beliefs within the same
family, it should be possible to have a
conversation with them
>> Yes.
>> and still love them and still respect
them. You know, of course people will
argue that there are extremes, there are
certain things that people can't get
over. Okay, but as a general principle,
you should be able to get on with people
who see the world differently than you
do.
>> Yes.
>> Which is something you don't see online
much. But if I think about even my best
mates from university, like there's four
or five of us and
you know, we're we'd be there for each
other, you know, we could rely on each
other for anything.
>> Mhm.
>> Doesn't mean we all see the world the
same way.
>> Right.
>> We we, you know, we have differences of
opinions and there's we're still best
mates.
>> Right.
>> But it seems as though the world, at
least online,
well, I say online it's getting more
divided, but that statistic would
suggest that actually offline as well
>> Yes.
>> more divided as well.
>> Yeah, I I definitely believe so because
we're not allowing real conversation. We
we expect that we can solve all issues
in one conversation. In fact, I'll go
even more. We feel like we can solve
everything and change someone's mind by
saying one sentence.
And we just think because I said it,
well then they have to wholeheartedly
swallow it, agree with it, take it and
say I'm the most amazing genius they've
ever heard. Yes, of course you're right.
And that's just never going to that's
never going to happen. And instead, you
have to see that if you want to change
someone's mind,
you better be ready to have
multiple conversations. I'm talking
conversations over years. Things that
you're going to have to invest in asking
questions and finding out why someone
believes what they do. When you actually
take the time,
rather than fighting
fighting the opinion they have, you take
the time to find out why they have it
exactly and how they learned it and
where they picked it up
and when they learned it. All of that
information is going to give you way
more knowledge and realize it's not the
symptom, it's the cause.
>> Yeah. Is it even possible to change
someone's mind? It's like
Maybe the goal is never to change
someone's mind. Maybe the goal should be
to learn.
>> Yeah, I like well
I would reframe that. The Yes, you can
change someone's mind, but what you said
is right. You have to change the goal.
Too often we put the
we put a bar
on conversations of and that bar is they
have to admit I'm right.
They have to say
they're wrong.
That is rarely, if ever, going to
happen. I can't get my child to say
that. I think I'm going to have someone
who's a grown adult say that who's had a
year or or years, a whole life of
experiences? And I think just because I
uttered sound into the air, they're
automatically just going to go
the scales have fallen from my eyes, how
wrong I am. That's not going to happen,
right? And so, you you can absolutely
change someone's mind, but one, you have
to live it. You can't just say it and
there be misalignment in how you're
you're living. Two, yes, evidence helps,
but sometimes when you're trying to push
your opinion
that makes me come closer more. So, for
example,
the more I tell you you're wrong,
the more convinced you're going to be
that you're right.
You're going to protect You're going to
protect what you know because this is
the one thing you feel like you do know,
that you're sure about. Why? Because
your dad told you about it when you were
five. You know, so you will wrap
yourself onto that that memory. So, can
you change someone's mind? Yes, 100% you
you can. But you cannot do it when you
raise the bar as I'm right, you're
wrong. Instead, I'm telling you to lower
the bar. That's what the book does. It
tells you to lower the bar. Instead of
saying, "I need to prove that I'm
right."
My goal is to understand where you're
coming from. My goal is to ask more
questions than I say things. My goal is
to Am I showing appreciation for the
time that we're spending in this
conversation? When you set the bar
really low, I'm just making sure you
feel understood and they feel
understood. They feel acknowledged. I
set a bar of how can I show that I
acknowledge them in this conversation?
That's going to lead to more of what you
want, rather than setting that bar
that's an that you can never meet.
>> Yeah.
Some of what you just said there speaks
to one of the other life lessons in the
book, which is never win an argument.
Yeah. What does that mean?
>> Whenever you set out to win an argument,
you will lose the relationship over
time.
If I were to say, "Do you know anybody
in your life who always has to be right?
They always have to have the final say.
They always have to have the last word."
Those kind of people aren't not someone
anybody wants to be around. It's
typically an audience of one. And the
more you try to win and prove, you will
lower the quality
and connection of that relationship.
What you really want is their contempt.
Let's say you and I are in an argument.
Rather than me trying to understand you,
I have to win. Win often sounds like I'm
the last one to talk.
That's what we typically have in
conversations. The one who says
something last
is the one who somehow wins. Maybe you
said something really ugly because you
and I have been personal friends for
forever, and I know that one button that
I can say that speaks right to your
insecurity, and all of a sudden you shut
down.
Does that mean I win?
Probably not, but that's the feeling.
Or, if you and I are in a conflict of
opinion, and I'm the one that says, "No,
I have to be right." And you go, "You
know what? Fine. You're right. You're
right."
Is that really winning?
Over time, they're going to feel
contempt for you. What you really want
is to be the first to apologize.
And that's that's kind of the procedure
of
of arguments. The person who said the
worst thing last is typically the one
who has to apologize first. What I like
to teach is instead of trying to win the
argument, you look to
unravel them. You find the knots in the
conversation and get really quick and
really proficient at loosening them.
>> Why do you think so many people take
things personally when having a
conversation?
>> Our default is to make things about me.
Make things about I.
Not so much you.
And it's just a shift of perspective
that we make everything
everything
about about us. Like as me, as an a um a
young associate at the law firm,
us associates um
would complain about the partners. We'd
go, "The partners don't care. Partners
don't listen to us. The part The all
they do is think about themselves."
When I made partner,
I got a within probably 5 minutes I got
an email and I thought, "These
associates,
all they do is care about themselves."
You know, it's a very us versus them
mentality. When you're the employee, you
hate the management. When you're the
management, you hate the employee. You
always find a way to make it about you.
It's it's our default. It's why we take
things personally. It's why when you if
I were to text you, "Okay." You're not
going to be Look at that. Look how nice
Jefferson is. He said, "Okay." in the
happiest way possible. Instead you're
going to go, "Okay. What kind of okay is
that? Is that like a Is that a okay
okay? Or is that like a okay?" Like what
We we find ways of reading the negative
in text and email, any transactional
correspondence like that. When we talk
about difficult, high-stress conflict,
I'm I'm talking about not just a little
bitty everyday arguments. I'm talking
about something that's on your plate
that's coming up right now and you go,
"Jefferson, I don't know how to handle
this. I I don't know what to do. I I I'm
afraid I'm going to shut down. I'm
afraid I'm going to get nervous." I'm
going to tell you exactly what I tell
every single one of my clients. You
ready? Number one,
it is not what you say. It is not
anything to do with your mouth. It has
everything to do with your
nervous system.
And the key here is instead of
absorbing,
you're observing.
I'm going to say it again. Instead of
absorbing,
you're observing. If you want to handle
conflict at a different level of
consciousness that you did not know you
could handle it,
it is going to be the key of not
absorbing what they say, but observing
what they say.
All right, say it with me. Say it with
me wherever you are. It's not absorbing,
it's observing.
All right, what does that mean?
I want you to think This is just coming
to me right now. I want you to think
you're in the grocery store and you have
your your cart with you and you're going
through and you or maybe maybe you're
somebody who likes a bag, you know, you
you you have a I'm I'm all for
environmentally friendly stuff, too,
though it's hard here in Texas.
And you have your cart.
And
you just start putting things on the
shelf
or grabbing things off the shelf and
putting it in your basket that you you
don't even want. Right? You don't even
want. And the things just start to come
in. You're like, "Yeah, you know what?
I'm going to take their belittling
opinion of me. I'm going to put it in my
cart. You know what? I'm going to take
their side eye, put it in my cart. I'm
going to take that that disrespectful
tone, and put that in my cart." And you
just keep going all the way through,
aisle by aisle, and then you go to
checkout,
which is actually a a very good word for
this. Yeah, you you you mentally check
out. And you know what checks in? Your
nervous system, your emotions. And they
just flood you in that moment. In in a
in that point in time, you have
absorbed, you have taken on so many
things that there's nothing left for
you.
You're not observing, you're not seeing
what's happening, you're just in it.
You're just in it, and you are helpless
to it. It is no longer you who controls
the emotions. The emotions are now
controlling you, and there's no telling
what you're going to say. There's no
There's no
Nobody can guess what's going to come
out of your mouth, or what's going to
happen, because you're not there. You
are checked out. So, when I tell my
clients, "Hey, when you're in the chair,
and somebody is the other attorney is
asking you questions, there's going to
be a time where all of a sudden you're
tempted to go in it.
To to to go down the spiral, and look
inside, and look at yourself, and feel
emotions, and get heated, because you're
going to start taking personally. You're
going to start absorbing what they're
saying. No, no, no, no. If you want to
handle this the right way, the proper
way in conflict, you have to start
observing. What does that mean? That
means you're going to approach the
conversation at a different level of
consciousness than you have before. That
means instead of going, "How How could
he say that to me? Oh my gosh, I'm
And you start
holding your breath, and you start
getting flustered, and you get nervous,
and maybe you tear up. It's because
you're not seeing it as, "Huh,
I wonder why he's asking me this. I
wonder why she's saying that. I wonder
where they're going with this."
Look for the intent behind the words.
The intent behind the words. When you
are observing what's happening, in some
sense being an attached observer. I've
said this before, where you it's like
you are sitting in a movie theater with
your popcorn, and you're watching the
conversation take place. And that puts
you in a different perspective of
looking at the person who's talking to
you.
And thinking, I wonder why that
character is saying this. I wonder what
the plot is. I wonder what the narrative
is. I wonder what scene is coming up
next. And you see how when you look at
it that way,
you have full control. You're now the
director, the producer, the screenwriter
of exactly what happens next. And then
it's just action. And you're able to be
in the state of mind of, hey, I'm
observing the conversation. And from
there, that gives you a chance to let
your body regulate because you're not in
it. You are seeing it. You're seeing the
conversation. Number two, what I teach
every one of my clients is something
that's at the forefront of my book, the
next conversation, argue less, talk
more. And rule number one, when I say
say it with control, and that is let
your breath
be the first word
that you say.
I've been talking a little fast here in
this podcast, which is unlike me. I
think I
I'll tell you why. I drink
too much coffee this morning. Too much
coffee, admittedly.
Usually I talk pretty slow, all right?
Can you hear how
just
the way I'm talking now,
and how I'm slowing down just a little
bit,
might in a micro
percentage
also slow you down
a little bit.
Maybe, you know, the neural activity in
your brain is starting to
slow down just a little bit. Maybe you
feel a little bit more relaxed at me
speaking a little more slowly. When I
put
breath
before my words,
it is making sure that I am regulating
myself.
And even more importantly, I am showing
you
I am showing you that I am regulated,
that I am in control.
And what I'm about to say, I've chosen.
I've chosen those words.
Makes a very big difference. So, when I
teach my clients, hey, don't get wrapped
up, don't try and step on somebody's
question, don't try to interrupt them,
let them get it out. And then you
observe the question, observe the the
interaction, take a breath.
And then choose what you want to say.
You are in complete control of the pace
of any conversation. Nobody can make you
say anything you don't want to say. And
nobody can make you say it at a time you
don't want to say it. That choice is
yours.
That choice is yours.
And I cannot tell you how many clients
I have seen come to find, accept, and
grow in their own power, and their own
sense of value and worth of wow, I
I get to choose if I say anything. And
you know what? If I want to wait 30
seconds before I say something, I can do
that.
Uh it's it is a freeing feeling to know,
mhm
No, I'm going to think about this. Let
me chew on this question for a second.
Just that alone,
the ability to say that
says, oh, no, no, I'm I'm operating at a
different level you don't know about.
No, I'm I'm not who you thought I was. I
know exactly what I'm doing. I'm going
to choose my words.
And I'm going to show you that what I'm
about to say is something that I
absolutely mean. And I'm saying with
intention.
All right, you can you feel the
difference? So, what kind of breath are
we talking about? I've run through this
breath before, it's always good to do it
because it's something that is good for
me, too. It's a conversational breath.
And what it does, it's based on a
physiological sigh, which is a double
Well, that kind of sounded weird. Double
inhalation.
A double inhalation. So, you're
breathing
you're inhaling twice. All right? So,
you ready with me? We're going to
breathe through your nose. Wherever you
are, just do it. Don't worry about it.
People might look at you. Don't worry.
Ready? We're going to breathe in through
your nose about 2 to 3 seconds.
One more at the top.
And then let out through your nose.
My guess is you're starting to come down
a little bit. Maybe your shoulders
relaxed a little bit.
It's the feeling that mimics a sigh.
When you use that kind of breath, and I
promise you
continue it while I'm talking right now.
You'll see that you get really good at
it. You can do it anytime.
The most crucial part for me is when I
teach my clients to do it is before they
answer the question. Just take
2 seconds
or 1 second. What we like to say here in
the South is just say one Mississippi.
In other words, in in your head you're
going to go
Mississippi.
Like what you you can use your own name
if you have a long name. You know, just
whatever it is. It's it's to get you in
the mindset of taking a beat, a moment.
Take that breath and choose what you
want to say. It is always going to be
better. And number three, the third
thing that I teach every single one of
my clients
is to use less words.
Say
less. Now, in the legal context, if my
witness
starts to give a very long answer, you
know what happens? Every Why do I say it
like that? Happens.
What happens is I guarantee them that
the opposing attorney is now going to
slice up
that long answer they just gave and turn
that into five more questions, 10 more
questions. The shorter the answer,
the stronger,
more
clear it is every single time. If I give
you an answer that is short and concise,
you can do nothing with it.
You can do nothing with it. Here's the
difference. So, I might have a client
who I've trained and we we practice a
lot. And when she might take a breath
and answer a question and go,
"No."
And that's it. That's the only answer.
What What can the other attorney do?
Nothing. They can't do anything with it.
They can only go to their next question.
But, I've also had it, despite my
training
and teaching, where somebody goes,
"You know, I'm not sure. You know, that
it was just such a hectic day and you
know, I forgot to go pick up the eggs
and my and my dog was sick and you know,
he just
it just, you know, peanut butter messes
up his system and I just find that and
you're going and I'm going, "Oh my gosh,
what is happening?" So, that happens.
That happens cuz people are are human.
Right? So, we have to take a break and I
go, "What What are we doing? Come on.
Get back in it with me." So,
you see the difference in if somebody's
giving a very long answer,
some practical things happen.
One is I'm get the witness is giving
more information than is needed.
Right? Unnecessary information, which
means the other person, let's put this
in everyday application. Everyday people
are going to get confused as to what the
answer is. They're going to fill in
their own assumptions of why you're not
answering it directly. They're going to
hear that there's just more words, which
just
automatically leads to the possibility
of more confusion and more
miscommunication. We don't want that. We
want short, concise. So, I like to say
it when I when I teach,
is that if I ask you,
"Do you have the time?
Do you know what time it is?"
That means I'm going to ask you to stop
and ask that question in my Do I know
what time it is? What am I asking?
Do you know what time it is?
And if you give me the time, "Oh, it's
um 8:03."
That's the wrong answer.
That's the wrong answer. If I say, "Do
you know the time?" The answer is yes, I
do. It's that detailed. It is that
detailed because in my world,
it has to be that detailed. You have to
be. And in everyday conversation, those
high-stake, high-emotion, just when
everything is on the the table,
everything's on the line,
every little word of clarity matters
a great deal.
And I have to make sure that you're
prepared.
So, when you condense your words into
something that is very short, very
concise,
the longer of an answer you give, the
more
opportunity there is for
miscommunication, more opportunity there
is for somebody to take your answer and
twist it. Here's an example. Have you
ever been in a text argument with
somebody?
I have. I know you have.
And it
they just sent you something and you're
like, "Oh, really?" And you just start
texting on your phone, just going after
it. And you write a paragraph. I'm
talking, you just you hit them so good
and it's perfect and you're it's it's
this is exactly how I feel.
And you send it and they send
a text that doesn't even address
anything that you said
at all. Or maybe they addressed one part
that they could defend and like, but
they ignored all the rest. It's that
same principle. You're giving someone
way too much to take and to twist. So,
if you want to handle high conflict,
like I teach every one of my clients,
you have to keep your answers as short
as possible. Answer their question and
only their question.
All right?
Okay. Hey, look, you're you're ready.
You're ready. I know we we maybe we're
going to need to talk about this. Let's
go grab some coffee, make sure you get
some snacks, feel good. We're about to
go into this deposition room together
and you're going to do awesome. I
promise. What did we talk about today?
When it comes to high-stakes
conversation, number one,
observe, don't absorb.
Observe, don't absorb. Number two, use
your breath
as the first word that you say. Slow it
down and choose your words. Be
intentional with them. Make sure that
you are operating on your time frame,
not somebody else's. And number three,
say less. Shorten your answers. When you
give way too much, you allow the
opportunity for somebody to grab onto
it, pieces, and say things you didn't
mean. You're giving them more to twist.
You're giving them more to twist. It's
like
giving somebody a long piece of rope.
They're able to put a bunch of knots in
it. But if you just give them a little
bit of rope, it maybe it's not even
enough to do a
the tie their shoe with, right?
It's a big difference. You want to make
sure that you're very short and concise.
Man, my um
examples today are all over the place.
We talked about the grocery store.
We talked about shoelaces. Man, what a
what a day. What an episode. Some things
that I wanted to share Mel of There are
some people that think that the Let Them
Theory has applied to these big, big
moments in their life, just like we were
talking about. And what I felt, and I
know what you have said, and I've just
been glued to your work, is that it
really does apply in every little
scenario. And what I thought of in my
mind,
and I just had such a wonderful
role role model in my life of my
parents,
so my dad would have used this theory
and not even It wasn't even the Let Them
Theory. So I I would bring something up
to him, and I'd be like, "Well, they're
going to be mad if we do that." And he'd
say, "Yeah, they're going to be mad."
I'd say, "Well, no, they're going to be
angry." He goes, "Yeah, I guess he'll be
mad about it." Like, it was just that.
Like, "Well, I guess he'll be mad."
Yeah. Or
uh this is one that would always get me.
We'd be driving down the two-lane
highway
and somebody I he's driving, I'm in the
passenger seat and somebody be right on
his bumper.
And I feel anxiety while I'm looking in
the the side mirror. I'm like, "Okay,
Dad, you got to speed up."
And I mean, without missing a beat, he
would just kind of pull over onto the
shoulder
and he would say out loud, "Go on with
your bad self."
That's what he'd say every time. Go on
with your bad self.
And so, it just it's like that now. We
all Everybody who's listening, if you're
a driver, you know what it's like that
you have somebody that's either wants to
pass you, you want to pass them, and
you're very vocal even when you drive of
everybody out there. They're either
going too slow,
you need to go faster, or somebody's
right behind you and you're going to
take that as some kind of challenge. Let
them theory applies especially in these
micro moments that really have nothing
even to do with one-on-one communication
with another person. It's that
self-communication that we talked about
at the beginning that it's often just
letting them
go and you're not going to let me take
the next step. Do I have that right,
Mel?
>> You not only have that right, but I want
to I want to unpack two really important
things there. So, the first thing I want
to unpack is the reason why the let them
theory is such a phenomenon
is that it does not exist in a vacuum.
>> Mhm.
>> I am reminding you
of what you know to be true. I am not
like I am not the first person In fact,
ever since we announced this book,
people have come out of the woodwork be
like, "Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh." TD Jakes
did a sermon 20 years ago.
Let them go.
Like there's there's the the Serenity
Prayer
is the let them theory. Buddhism,
radical acceptance, stoicism.
The
uh peaceful like protest. This is all
about controlling your response. If
you've read Man's Search for Meaning,
Victor Frankl, the entire book is about
the power of attitude and how the things
out there
you can't control,
but they don't have to impact what
you're thinking about in here.
These are powerful concepts that have
been woven through spiritual teachings,
philosophy, therapeutic modalities since
the beginning of time.
I have just taken all of that and turned
it into a simple tool that you activate
with two words, let them and let me.
And, you know, for me, in my family, my
mom is literally like, I've lived like
this my entire life. In fact, she had a
pillow that said, "Pull up your big girl
panties and deal with it." That's let
me. That's let me and my mother said.
And so, the reason why I also believe
that this has exploded is because you
are being reminded of what you already
know to be true.
>> Yes.
>> You are also being handed a tool, and
this is happening at a moment in history
that
feels at unprecedented levels like
everything is out of control.
And the headlines are overwhelming,
people's stress levels are overwhelming,
everybody has somebody in their family
who is profoundly struggling, people are
worried about the economy, they're
worried about their kids, they're
worried about the future, and it doesn't
matter where you live or who you are.
People are worried about AI. All of this
feels like it is out of control, and
this is ultimately a book about control.
And how when you try to control things
that you can't control, like other
people's opinions or their moods or
their attitudes or how fast they drive
or slow they drive or whether or not
they ride the bumper, it just creates
stress for you.
>> As somebody who gives advice on a lot of
different formats on how to connect with
people and how to handle conflict, often
some of the most important conversations
are self-communication. What you say to
yourself. That's why therapy is
something that you need to be doing. I
go to therapy. There's nothing wrong
with it. It's getting conversations out
of your head and just talking about it.
It's more helpful than you think. A
sponsor of this podcast, BetterHelp, is
an online platform that helps connect
you to a licensed therapist just for
that purpose. And it's real easy. All
you do is just fill out a survey and
they connect you with a therapist that's
right for you. And if it's not a good
match, no problem. They'll at no cost
fix you up with another one. And it's
very important to get these
conversations out of your head.
Relationships come with questions.
Therapy comes with answers. You can go
to betterhelp.com/jeffersonfisher
for a discount on your first month of
therapy. I highly recommend it.
>> And the real power in life, whether
you're learning through it through
stoicism or you're learning about it
through Victor Frankl's work or you're
learning about it through radical
acceptance, is in focusing on what you
can control, which is your response,
your attitude, what you choose to do or
don't do in response to the things
around you. And the second thing I
wanted to say about that story because I
absolutely
love it. And we can all relate to that.
Just pull over and just, you know, what
How did your dad say it? Let your bad
self by or what did he what
>> He'd say, "Go on with your bad self."
>> Go on with your bad self. That Yeah,
yeah, you're just so like, "Go on with
your bad self." You're acknowledging the
negative energy. You're You're allowing
it, right? So now you're in control.
It's not like he's run you off the road.
You're like, "All right, go on with your
bad self. I'm in control here
because I'm choosing to pull over. And
I'm choosing to recognize your energy is
not affecting me. And this is the second
thing that's actually really, really
important.
So,
you talked about being in the passenger
seat and feeling that volcano of
stressful energy
rise up in your body.
>> Mhm.
>> And the reason why it's important to use
the let them theory in the micro
moments, standing in line,
and it's taking too long,
dealing with a frustrating customer
service issue,
having somebody be rude to you. Like all
these little things, people like
stopping in front of you and then that
like whatever it rude behavior. Let
them, let them, let them. Because every
time you say let them,
just like with your dad go on with your
bad self. Just like when you do that,
what you're doing is you're not allowing
dumb things on the outside to actually
steal your life force.
>> Yeah.
>> And what I realized, Jefferson, is that
I had no idea
how
even just 2 years ago, the age of 54, I
would come barreling in
to my home at the end of the day,
completely stressed out from work and
emails and Zoom calls and the long lines
and the traffic commute home. And I, you
know, throw my bag down and yeah, I'm
all razzled and stressed out from all
these micro moments
where I'm letting the stress rise up.
And then what do I do? I snap at my
kids.
>> Right.
>> And you taught me something.
You taught me a saying that I said that
I taught to my family to say to me,
which is, you know, I'm really sorry for
what your work stress did to you, but
you're going to have to apologize for
what your work stress is doing to me.
>> Mhm.
>> And it wasn't until
I learned to say let them, and I started
protecting myself
from the unnecessary stress and
frustration
of all the things that happen in modern
life,
that I actually got on the other side of
this problem
and I can now walk in
to my house at the end of the day
and not vomit all of that frustration
and stress on my kids and my husband.
And the reason why this matters is
because I think it's very hard or at
least it's very hard for me
to communicate effectively or to
communicate like a mature adult
or with kindness
when I am stressed out
>> Mhm.
>> or I am frustrated or I am tired.
And it has been a life-changing
experience in terms of the level of
peace in our household and the amount of
safety that I think my family feels
around me like, "Oh, what kind of We all
have that person in our family, what
kind of mood are they going to be when
they come home?" Well, that was me.
Cuz I was constantly allowing everything
to get to me and then I would get home
and I'm like a raw wire and then that's
when you use that tone or that's when
you say something you regret or you send
that snarky email. And saying let them
let them let them
and protecting my peace
has made me a better communicator
overall because I'm actually calm and
centered when I'm opening my mouth at
the end of the day.
>> So good. So good. I love these moments
of you turning what would be an
exasperated sigh that
into
let them
and let me take an intentional breath.
You know,
let me turn that into something that is
really going to serve me and in my
purpose of where I want to go rather
than I have no control. Let me just let
out a sigh that is like letting
everybody know how
aggravated and annoyed I am and how much
of an inconvenience they are. I think
that is incredibly powerful. If you
enjoyed that clip and want to see the
rest of the conversation, you can click
right here. Or if you want to see the
latest episode of the Jefferson Fisher
podcast, click right here and I'll meet
you there.